tension is growing in Washington over
the Trump administration's
zero-tolerance policy letting border
security agents separate the children of
immigrants trying to enter the US
illegally the president is holding
Democrats responsible for what he calls
a horrible law that created the
conditions that requires the separations
critics say there is no law requiring
families to be split up major Garrett is
at the White House major good morning
good morning the number of illegal
border crossers this April three times
larger than last April that increase has
led to intense friction between
President Trump and homeland security
secretary Kirsten nielsen so much so
Nielsen's long term cabinet job security
is now in question in response the
administration now separates any
undocumented immigrant caught at the
border from children traveling with them
this the administration says ought to
discourage future attempts at crossing
the border we need strong
immigration laws president Trump's
crackdown on illegal crossings on the
us-mexico border is now more intense
than ever
homeland security secretary Kirsten
Nielsen on May 4th ordered federal
prosecution against any individual
caught crossing the border illegally as
a result those adults traveling with
children are now being separated once
detained because children cannot be held
in adult jails between May 6th and May
19th 638 adults were referred for
prosecution those adults brought with
them a total of 658 children all of whom
were separated from the adults they
traveled with secretary Neilson recently
defended the move United States if you
break the law you go to jail and you're
separated from your family shouldn't be
any different for illegal immigrants in
a statement a White House spokesman said
Democrats are responsible for the
separations quote because they refuse to
close border loopholes that prevent
those families from being swiftly
returned home a DHS official told CBS
News that of the children separated from
their parents quote most likely they've
been reunited the official provided no
specifics this is the most horrific
practice I have seen in the 25 plus
years American Civil Liberties Union
attorney legal earned has sued the Trump
administration that kind of said
operation last potentially a lifetime
where you the child no longer feels like
the parent can protect them the
administration is also denying reports
that had lost track of nearly 1500
children captured at the border and now
in custody from last year the Department
of Health and Human Services said in a
statement those children are lost their
sponsor simply did not respond to a call
asking them if they required additional
services Norah all right major thank you